it is now my great honor to introduce
the president of the United States of
America Joe Biden
he didn't have much time to spare this
was the president's only engagement in
Northern Ireland where efforts to
preserve Pace unite a polarized America
supporting the people of Northern
Ireland protecting the peace preserving
the Belfast Good Friday agreement is a
priority
for Democrats and Republicans alike in
the United States and that is unusual
today
Joe Biden had met privately with the
main political leaders before publicly
appealing for a restoration of power
sharing at Stormont
as a friend I hope it's not too
presumptuous for me to say that I
believe Democratic institutions
established the Good Friday agreement
remained critical to the future of
Northern Ireland
it's a decision for you to make not for
me to make
but the dups already made its decision
rejecting Rishi sunak's New brexit Deal
so did the president's words change
anything well it's good to have the
president of the United States here in
Belfast we welcome him as we welcome all
visitors but I don't think it changes
the political dynamic or the reality
that what we need is the reassurance
that our place within the United Kingdom
is both respected and protected well I
mean I very much welcome the fact that
they have had such a strong commitment
to our peace process over the last 25
years and I asked him to stay at the
course with us and and very much
welcomed the fact that he has been very
young people focused on this visit that
he has been talking about Prosperity
opportunity opportunity for investment
so in the quick conversation trying to
get all those things in was my challenge
but I think I've actually did that the
Good Friday agreement has enabled a
generation to grow up in peace including
the former student who introduced him I
think today has just been a reminder of
how far we've come in the last 25 years
and now of course there is still works
today but how resilient and capable our
generation is to be able to make that
piece happen in the coming 25 years
this speech could be summed up in one
word potential the president urging
Northern Ireland's political leaders not
to miss the opportunity that exists for
significant economic investment here if
there's a stable government
there was a brief bilateral with the
Prime Minister both leaders in Belfast
marking 25 years since the historic
compromise President Biden and I spoke a
lot about that and we spoke in
particular about the incredible economic
opportunities that are there in store
for Northern Ireland and we talked about
the investment potential that is there
the companies that want to invest in
Northern Ireland I think that's
incredibly exciting or been growth jobs
and prosperity to Northern Ireland and I
know he shares my ambition to see the
institutions here back up and running
and his message to this audience could
not have been clearer when it comes to
preserving peace and restoring power
sharing in this corner of the UK America
is still in the picture David Blevins
Sky News in Belfast